Episode 1 of The Expanse Season 5 starts with
scientists who find some mysterious new asteroids.
They’re excited by their discovery – but
these rocks are not a natural accident.
The ship is attacked by a team led by Filip
– the son of Marco Inaros and Naomi.
Cause Marco and his Belter extremists have
launched asteroids to hit Earth, coated in
stealth tech so they’re invisible.
Looks like one of them broke up near the sun,
and these scientists detected the fragments.
So to keep the attack secret, Filip kills
the scientists, and blows up the evidence.
One of Filip’s men gets stuck, and Filip
leaves him to die.
So how will Naomi react when she learns that
her son has grown up to be a ruthless murdering
extremist, like his dad?
And will these rocks be stopped before they
hit Earth and kill millions?
This attack was foreshadowed from the start.
In Season 1, Avasarala said she worries about
“people who throw rocks”.
A Belter said a “hail of stones” “will
one day come crashing down through” Earth’s
“precious blue skies”.
This attack expresses centuries of Belter
resentment for their oppression by the inner
planets.
On Tycho Station, the Rocinante’s in for
repairs.
The new chief engineer, Sakai, says the ship
is badly damaged, partly because they used
a rail gun as a thruster last season.
But she says the Roci was built strong by
the “dusters”.
Duster is a slang term for ‘Martian’ used
by Belters and Earthers.
Just as Belters are called “skinnies”,
and in the books Earthers are called “squats”.
But one of Naomi’s best friends is Martian,
and she asks Sakai not to use this derogatory
slur.
In Book 3, Anna says that these kinds of words
are dehumanising.
When groups think of each other as dusters
and skinnies instead of as people, it justifies
cruelty and conflict.
These tribal factional divisions and their
terrible consequences are what this show is
all about.
Way back in Season 1, Naomi asked Fred to
help her find Filip.
Now he delivers, and for the first time in
years, Naomi sees her son’s face.
Naomi left Marco cause she didn’t want to
be involved in his terrorism.
But she always felt guilt that she couldn’t
take Filip with her.
Now might be her chance to save her son.
On the news, people are flooding through the
Ring gates to colonise the new worlds beyond.
That’s thanks to Nancy Gao, the new Secretary-General
of the United Nations, who beat Avasarala
in the election by arguing for faster expansion
to the new worlds.
Avasarala argued that it’s too dangerous
for people to settle these distant unknown
planets full of dangerous alien technology
– like, Ilus almost blew up, the Ring almost
wiped out the solar system, Eros almost destroyed
Earth.
And they’re already finding more protomolecule
structures on these new worlds.
So are the rewards worth the risk?
Holden sees Monica, the journalist from Season
3.
She’s investigating reports that someone
in the Belt is secretly experimenting with
the protomolecule.
In Season 2, Dresden and Cortázar said the
protomolecule has the potential to transform
and empower humanity.
But it also could destroy us.
Monica says Holden has a responsibility to
protect the world from alien threats – but
Holden refuses her and leaves.
Holden constantly wrestles with feeling responsible
to save the world.
Time and time again he tries to let go of
leadership and heroism , but every time, he
comes back – Holden can’t stop himself
from saving people . It’s how he was raised,
it’s who he is.
Fred Johnson admits to Holden that he and
the OPA are experimenting with the protomolecule.
Holden says it’s too dangerous, and brings
up the artifact on Ilus.
The protomolecule and the Ring were created
by an alien civilisation called the Builders,
but some other entities killed the Builders
using these artifacts.
Elvi is studying the artifact, and she says
it seems connected to human consciousness.
Holden has a special connection to the alien
technology thanks to the ghost of Miller.
So when Holden goes through the Ring, he sees
these entities.
It looks like they exist in like the warp
space between the wormholes of the Ring.
On Fred’s table, there’s a tesseract or
four-dimensional cube, which might hint that
these entities are somehow inter-dimensional.
Whatever they are, Holden says they’re angry,
and he fears that messing with alien technology
could wipe out humanity.
Fred says it’s probably fine bro and that
Holden should relax, go build a farm, take
up yoga, cause if Holden’s always worrying
about death and destruction, is he really
living?
On Mars, Bobbie investigates a conspiracy
– she believes that powerful people in the
Martian military are selling weapons to the
Belt.
Avasarala is funding her investigation.
Then Bobbie gets a message from Katlin.
Katlin was the wife of Esai, who trafficked
stolen Martian tech last season.
He did this in the hope of providing a better
life for his wife and children, like a Martian
Walter White.
But this conspiracy was bigger and more dangerous
than he realised, and Esai was killed.
So now Bobbie helps Esai’s family by giving
them money for a new life beyond the Ring
– maybe she uses Avasarala’s money.
So this is a kind and generous act by Bobbie
to fulfil Esai’s dying wish.
Hopefully the world that Esai’s family go
to is safer than Ilus was.
Alex flies to Mars in the Razorback – this
was Julie Mao’s racing ship, that Bobbie
and Avasarala once used.
When Alex was in the Mars Navy, they said
he didn’t have what it takes to fly their
best ships.
So now, Alex comes back and shows off his
sweet ride to the people who said he wasn’t
good enough.
He’s back on Mars to try to reconnect with
his ex-wife Talissa, and his son, Melas.
Alex had left his family behind to go be a
pilot – for a while, they thought he was
dead.
Alex said he loves Talissa and Melas, but
feels that flying on the Roci, and doing good,
is more important to him.
But last season, Alex met Lucia, and saw her
struggle to keep her family together.
So now Alex wants make peace with his own
family.
He visits Talissa, and tries to apologise,
but she doesn’t wanna hear it.
He was gone for too long, she’s moved on,
and she doesn’t want to deal with him.
So he calls his son Melas, and tries to be
a Dad, he says “I love you” – but his
son doesn’t say “I love you” back.
So Alex does what anyone would do, and starts
drinking.
The bar has a Texan cowboy theme – they
play country and western music sung in Chinese.
Because many of the original settlers of the
Mariner Valley on Mars were from China, East
India and Texas – and clearly the Texan
aesthetic stuck.
Alex meets with Bobbie, but she’s not in
the mood to hang out.
She’s.. preoccupied with the massive military
conspiracy thing, and she talks about the
dying dream of Mars.
Now that the Ring is open, people are leaving
Mars to go colonise new worlds, unemployment
is rising, it’s like the planet is dying.
In the book, they call it a “Ghost world”.
Alex talks about persisting to reconnect with
Talissa and Melas, but Bobbie says he’s
gotta let it go.
Maybe Alex needs a new purpose, a new home.
Maybe every Martian does.
Amos takes a ship towards Earth.
He’s going to Baltimore, because a woman
he knew there called Lydia has died – we
saw him looking up Lydia in Season 2.
On the ship, he looks meaningfully at this
sleeping older woman – she’s about the
same age that Lydia would be now.
The show hasn’t revealed anything about
Lydia yet – just that she’s someone who
looked after Amos when he was younger.
Some thugs try to shake down the ship’s
passengers for money.
So Amos threatens violence.
He talks about how he can hold his breath
for a long time, because on these ships, if
there’s a fight, the crew uses knockout
gas to put everyone down.
Amos is saying that if they get gassed, he’ll
just hold his breath and beat up these thugs
anyway.
The passengers say Amos shouldn’t have antagonised
those guys – they would rather pay the protection
money than risk violence.
Amos put them in danger.
That’s the thing about Amos and violence
– he says that it’s pragmatic, that he’s
solving problems and surviving.
But sometimes, Amos just gets people hurt,
including his friends, and himself.
He goes and beats up the thugs with his fists
and feet and a toothbrush, then in the shower,
he looks hurt but cleansed, there’s dark
organ music playing like some ominous church.
Amos didn’t fight these guys to protect
the passengers, he says he did it for himself.
At this point in the book, Amos feels physically
unwell, and he thinks he’s getting sick.
What’s really happening is he’s grieving
Lydia, but Amos is so repressed and detached
from his emotions that he can’t directly
feel them.
His emotions just come out through his body,
and through violence.
The only way he knows how to feel better is
to hurt people.
On the way to Earth, Amos is intercepted by
Avasarala.
She mentions the time that Amos taught her
how to walk in mag boots.
Amos had said it’s like walking in pumps,
like high heels, and she asked why he knows
what that’s like and he said he “didn't
always work in space”.
It sounds like just a funny lil throwaway
line, but it actually hints at Amos’ traumatic
past.
He’s mentioned before that he grew up around
brothels.
He says he’s known paedophiles, and people
who exploit children.
And that when he was five, he lived in a basement.
Amos suffered a horrific traumatic childhood.
Returning to Baltimore means facing the past,
and reflecting on the man he became.
Avasarala sends Amos on his way.
Since Nancy Gao became Secretary-General,
Avasarala is still in government, but not
as powerful as she once was.
This guy Admiral Delgado brings her evidence
that Marco destroyed that science ship earlier.
But they don’t know why.
Will Avasarala find out Marco’s plan before
the rocks hits Earth?
The scientists who saw the rocks mention checking
their data with scientists on Luna – where
Avasarala is now – so maybe that’s how
Avasarala will find out about the asteroids.
Avasarala’s main goal has always been to
protect her home.
And Marco’s attack threatens everything
she’s fought for.
Naomi tells Holden that she’s found her
son Filip.
She’s going to go see him, try to save him,
and she’s going alone.
Cause this’ll be a delicate and dangerous
and personal reunion, with a Belter extremist.
Bringing Holden would only complicate the
situation – he’s a famous Earther hero
who’s completely unable to not get involved
in things, so she leaves him behind.
In Season 3, Naomi told Holden that she won’t
leave him again, that they’re “Together
till the end”.
But like Alex and Amos, Naomi needs to face
her past, alone.
And with all his crew gone, Holden is alone
too.
Holden grew up with eight parents.
He’s always been around family and friends
in the Navy and the Cant and the Roci.
Now, he’s “truly alone for the first time
in years”.
The title of this episode is Exodus.
It refers to the flood of colonists leaving
their homes for new worlds, and it refers
to Alex and Amos and Naomi leaving the Roci
for their own quests.
What trials and tribulations will they face,
and how will they be changed?
Thanks for watching, and please subscribe
to this channel.
Cause Amazon Prime UK was nice enough to sponsor
this video and provide early episodes.
Comment below if you want more videos about
The Expanse.
Thank you to our Patrons, including Alarian,
Wess Lútathánkat, Stephanie Auer, Jorge
Eduardo Phillips Cantillo, Nina, and Sir Roger
the Knight Cook.
Cheers.